in the lobby of the headquarters of
Ramsey solutions die-in is with us hey
Diane how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve where are you from
Houston Texas all right and here to do
your debt-free scream yes sir
before I forget what are you thankful
for my family and my support system that
have helped me through this journey
perfect how much dad have you paid off
thirty-eight thousand four hundred forty
eight dollars and 64 cents I love it and
how long did that take you about three
and a half years excellent very well
done
making what kind of money when I started
I was making about forty five thousand
now I make about fifty four good for you
what do you do for a living I was a
teacher and I still work in education
but now I handle all the state testing
for my school oh wow
good for you okay so what kind of debt
was the thirty eight thousand the
majority of it was credit cards and my
car ah okay and three and a half years
ago something happened I what happened I
got fed up I just got tired of living
and not being able to do anything and
just trying to outrun my bills so I
decided I wanted to do something
differently okay and then what happened
and then I a series of things I started
with a ELP license counselor then I went
to and that kind of got me going but I
still wasn't my teeth weren't in it and
I went to see a live event in Houston
you came okay on October 8th 2011 and
that's really that was my tipping point
and I just hit the ground running and
kind of never looked back very cool so
that put the lit the fire the rest of
the way it was kind of smoldering we
threw a little gas on it very cool very
cool so you fought your way through this
for three and a half years you've been
on a tight budget watching what you're
doing you're single uh-huh good good for
you and you scratched and clawed your
way through it so what was the hardest
part of this process the hardest part
was being a twenty-something and you
know having to give up those things that
we do and you know not being able to go
on all the trips and not being able to
go out all the time going to eat going
out with my friends just making those
sacrifice
is but I had an end result I had a goal
that I wanted to do it by the time I was
30 and I wanted to spend the summer of
my 30th birthday in Europe Wow
and I to date at two months before my
30th birthday I paid off all my debt and
I spent three and a half weeks in Europe
this summer
fleetly cash cash flow the whole trip
your debt from the trip and it was an
amazing experience to go over there and
and be among it and not have to worry
about where I was gonna pay for it all
because it was already paid for it's
amazing yeah the best trips are the ones
that don't follow you home exactly yeah
very cool well congratulations
nice reward for yourself yeah very cool
also how you live like no one else later
you can live and give like no one else
and now you're in that position so now
obviously you've paid yourself back with
a good Europe trip a nice little
checkmark on the box there that part
aside how does it feel to not have any
debt if it's great I mean I can do
whatever I want with my money I'm
working through my baby step number
three my fully funded emergency fund so
and then on the radar I want to be able
to purchase a house and put a hefty
downpayment and then pay it off early
good for you excellent so three and a
half years ago you came out of that
Total Money Makeover they were called in
those days live event there in Houston
it was probably at the big arena and we
used to do them there yeah reliant on
reliant arena I was trying to remember
which whether that was Dallas or Houston
to rely on I always get them confused
but um yeah and so we had you know what
four or five six thousand people in
though that's probably ten thousand in
there give or take anyway and you come
out of there
fired up mm-hmm and you're looking at
this $38,000 Mountain right in front of
you when when you got to the top of the
mountain the other day when you paid off
the last debt and you look back was that
journey harder or easier than you
thought it was going to be when you were
standing at the bottom it was it was
easier than I thought it was going to be
when I was standing at the bottom I
thought there's no way I was ever going
to get out of this it was I was just
this was gonna be my life forever it was
never gonna happen and
standing on the other side I was like oh
wow I did this it can be done and it
just takes a little bit of perseverance
and a plan and I always plan every time
I got my email with my pay stub every
dollar every cent went to something on
paper and I'm a spreadsheet girl my
friends tease me about it and if they're
teasing you you're doing it right and so
I tracked everything every penny that
went towards anything I attracted I had
charts that showed me where I was going
along the way because I needed to have
those milestones and I needed to be able
to celebrate along the way because after
you pay off a couple debts then you have
these big ones
yup that you don't really see the light
at the end of the tunnel right away so
seeing those really truly making those
baby steps and seeing that in the finish
line get closer and closer made it a lot
easier than I thought it was going to be
absolutely well congratulations Diane
thank you I'm very very proud of you
thank you you are incredible you're a
rock star so 30 years old I've spent
spent the summer in Europe I paid cash
for it I paid off thirty eight thousand
dollars in debt three and a half years
making forty five to fifty four count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one I'm debt free
I love it I love it I love it
excellent job